do you see a deal what percentage too
attached to a deal that what percentage
probability right now I think it's hard
to put an exact percentage on it but i
would say at the moment I think deal is
still looking more likely than not make
sure there's some very tough
negotiations going in at the moment but
we can still see the broad outlines of a
mutually agreeable nuclear framework now
having said that there are still some
very difficult issues that need to be
resolved and the main one probably being
the pace at which sanctions are lifted
and also the details of the inspections
regime essentially Iran wants to see
sanctions lifted more or less
immediately whereas the u.s. probably
visitors more of a gradual lifting in
parallel with verification of Iranian
compliance and how have we got to this
has this been through compromise driven
by political will just pure political
will to get a deal done on both sides
yeah I mean if you look at both sides
and it was clearly a very very strong
need from both the Iranians and the
Americans for a deal if you look at the
Iranians the economic issues clearly
like the main driving factor here me if
you look at the Iranian economy back in
2013 it was really on the ropes they
made some sort of economic adjustments
back then cut public spending and things
started to look a little bit better so
in some ways of easing the pressure on
Iran but then of course since then we've
had the old price oil price slide which
has you know put pressure on the Iranian
economy and that's been a big factor and
the American side is probably more
prestige issue for Obama this has been
his main foreign political objective and
you know the administration has really
struggled in the Middle East for any
sort of foreign political successes so
this is really sort of their main target
one thing that strikes me is that
despite the fact that the Iranian
economy is in but he crushed by the
sanctions that opinion polls that we
have suggest that the people are so very
much in support of the nuclear program
not necessarily weaponry but the nuclear
program and very much blame the
Americans the Europeans etc for the
crushing impact of the sanctions which
is similar perhaps to in Russia where
the people blame and knock knock putas
decisions over Ukraine but the Europeans
Americans for the impact of the
sanctions on their economy so even when
assuming conditions are lifted there is
an agreement in place
adds up what does that mean for
relations between Iraq and particular
America got me forward when there's so
much blame yeah well I think yeah the
scale is a problem here with distrust
and mutual suspicions and I think
initially the worst kind of this hope
that these negotiations would lead to
some web rapprochement between the u.s.
and Iran but that's looking increasingly
unlikely I think now the scope
negotiations have become very very
narrow it's really just boiled down to
the nuclear program itself and any sort
of ideas that this might you know
strengthen more moderate elements in
Iran or sort of temporary runs behave in
the region I think that is looking
increasingly likely and I think you know
if you look at the Saudi position then
their concern is that this deal could
actually make tensions worse I mean they
are concerned that Iran's role in the
region hasn't been part of negotiations
and that in as a rapport sanctions Iran
could be emboldened to act much more
forcefully in the region I was going to
ask you about that very point to be on
how will Iran behave in the region after
a deal is done does it change anything
about how active they are in various
regional conflicts I think about that
well it Yemen in particular is one of
them yeah I think Yemen and Syria
especially a very good examples we've
seen already in Syria Iran step up its
involvement as Bashar al-assad comes
under a stronger pressure so clearly
when if you're looking at some kind of
India lifting and freezing of sanctions
then you know Iran will be given access
to you know dozens the billions of
dollars but perhaps more than a hundred
billion dollars and it's likely that you
know a significant portion of that will
go to sort of foreign political
adventures like Yemen and Syria so i
think yes you know there is quite a high
risk that Iran will feel emboldened to
act more forcefully and they know that
the Americans particular do not want to
jeopardize the deal so they feel that
they have a bit more leeway to act a bit
more forcefully and we've seen that in
you know in the region recently we've
seen a number of oil companies talking
about either well some of them are
already doing business there but or
starting to do business they're talking
about doing business there how difficult
is that going to be though do you think
I think it will be difficult I mean
first of all Iran will clearly be a huge
opportunity for our gas companies and
it's got the third largest oil and gas
reserves in the
world and it could probably start an
increasing production of crude oil
relatively rapidly one sanctions are
lifted of course projections will vary
depending on how quickly sanctions are
lifted and how they are lifted but if we
assume that there is some kind of
agreement within the next few weeks and
that oil sanctions are gone by the
middle of next year then Wood Mackenzie
expects Iran to be able to add around
600,000 barrels per day of crude oil
production to global supply by the end
of 2017 but as you say clearly companies
would face on some pretty significant
operational challenges in Iran if you
look at the record of European oil and
gas companies during the 2000s it's not
great they play they face in very
difficult problems I think probably the
main one was you know the unattractive
fiscal terms which you ran off with oil
and gas companies and it now appears
that they are committed to improving
those we'll have to wait and see but you
know they are in competition with other
countries so they will have to improve
that but even leaving that aside you
also have other problems such as a
bloated petroleum bureaucracy political
risks both regionally undomesticated so
huge problems